i went to disney jail and this is that
story there are a lot of different ways
you can find yourself in disney jail
some are weirder than others but no
matter the reason it's not a place you
want to see
i was just a freshman and it was me and
my friend and we went on our first
friend you know little trip vacation so
my friend decided to wear a tube top
because hey it was hot and b she was
trying to look cute
and that wasn't the best idea to do but
at the time i wasn't thinking about it
she wasn't thinking about it so me and
my friends
playing a trip to go to florida i've
never been to disney i never even been
to florida so i was pretty late i was
excited i'm like oh i'm so ready to go
let's go let's go we get to the hotel
the hotel's big lit
everything's looking nice we like the
spark up get mellow get lit
get you know like okay this is gonna be
a good side baby so we went to disney
world my friend was like all right look
i have this brownie i was already lit i
was at full capacity
i was just hungry i wasn't trying to get
higher i just want to eat the food
he didn't even tell me it was edible i
that's so quick i was like
um worst mistake shouldn't have eat the
whole brownie
it was the week that the donald trump
animatronic was being unveiled at the
hall of presidents and i
happen to be going down with my family
for like
christmas vacation for those of you who
don't know what the hall of presidents
ride is it's really just an excuse for
like
tired parents to like force their kids
to take a nap for 20 minutes in the park
air conditioned and it's a whole history
of the presidents the united states
and then at the end whoever is the
current president
recites the uh oath of office so we went
to the
infamous flash mountain we got on the
ride everything was going good we were
now
screaming and having a good time
laughing and as soon as the
the picture part came we decided to do
the hands up pose like oh we
were going down and honestly that wasn't
the best thing to do
i heard her like say oh my gosh like
from the corner of my eyes i could like
see her like
bring her arms down and like hug herself
and i'm just like
did that just happen like i knew what
happened but i didn't want to believe it
okay
as the ride was slowing down i was like
what happened she was like my top went
down so
when we were waiting for the ride to
slow down and to stop and you know like
the little bars and stuff had to come up
like she was about like lift the bars of
herself it
was possible we have to hurry up and get
out before anyone else got us you know
kids are fast and we like rush to like
the little monitors
and that's basically what was on the
monitor and it was so embarrassing
i've never had edible in my life so at
this point i am just
wigging out i'm seeing all types of
stuff everything was very amplified it
was like a lot of beautiful light colors
brown colors
i was wobbling around like this i
already got a bad leg so you already
know i wasn't lean with a rock with a
lean with a rock with it families were
staring at me like who the hell and what
the hell is this
so as soon as donald trump's animatronic
started
saying the oath of office i stood up
and started screaming lock him up lock
him up
lock him up i would not stop until they
shut down the ride
which they did okay so we're blocking
monster
and you know of course some people want
to be nosy because people can't mind
their business
kids coming over and we're just like no
sorry you cannot see this monitor
and it wasn't even to be mean but it was
like it's for your own good
because we're probably gonna get in
trouble and your parents are gonna get
mad and next thing you know it these two
people came
i guess secrets undercover people
whatever
and they're like we need you um two to
come with us and i'm just like
what like i was so scared and i was okay
so where are we going
exactly and so they're like you know we
have to take you like to disney jail
right quick and my heart
sank like the only thing i could think
of was okay we're going to pay a fine
we're getting kicked out i was so scared
so
i ended up going to the side by myself
kind of trying to find a way to get away
from everybody and i'm like let me just
roll up again because maybe i'm bugging
i start going up again and then this guy
comes up to me he goes hey come with me
i'm like who the hell is this who the
hell are you there were lots of kids
crying because and
lots of parents crying too because i
definitely interrupted their kid's naps
most of the audience didn't like me
there was i remember one burly man
coming up and being like
if you don't shut up i will beat you
up or something like that and i was like
okay come on that's a puppet
and then i was carted off to disney jail
and so they let us like this room
it's not like a you know a theme jail as
some people might say it's no
it's a small world playing it's none of
that stuff it's no bars
it's just a regular room a desk little
decorations i guess and that's it
it's just there's lights there's there's
windows so at this point i am just
wigging out i'm seeing all types of
stuff i was hallucinating od when he was
interrogating me i felt like the [ __ ]
keeper was interrogating me with all
these eyes and i kept seeing this like
little girl at the corner of my eyes she
was little she was dressed in white and
every time i was turning around she was
just there before my eye
i felt like i was in the scariest dark
raid of the park i think
once they realized i was not a
legitimate threat
they were like you can go but they did
say you can't come back to the hall of
presidents ever and i was like i mean
how would you ever know but
i mean i would love if there is some
picture of me in like the hall of
president's entrance that's like
this person cannot enter and so she
decided to let us off with a warning
she was actually really super nice she
gave us like some candy afterwards so
and that made us definitely feel better
we honestly didn't give no rise after
that
but after i said what i said they're
like they kind of banned me they banned
me
the real jail is the outside world
because i'm banned i'm clipped they
banned me for a whole year
tucker carlson's daily caller whatever
website
called me the saddest man in america
but then like a week later salon.com
said i was like the voice of 2017
because i was like this person
screaming into a dark room
at something that wouldn't be able to
hear me
or do anything about what i was saying
so i love that i thought that i was like
that's perfect that i can i can die
happy knowing that
my advice don't wear a tube top to
disney world
or any amusement park in general wear
one with straps
you